[Music]
Brett Kavanaugh and his wife actually
appeared on the story with Martha
McCallum just an hour ago on the show he
categorically denied all allegations of
sexual misconduct levied against him
I've never sexually assaulted anyone not
in high school
not ever I've always treated women with
dignity and respect listen to the people
who've known me best through my whole
life the women who've known me since
high school the 65 who overnight signed
a letter from high school saying I
always treated them with dignity and
respect
Cavanaugh's wife of course came to the
defense of her husband as well I know
Brad I've known him for 17 years and
this is not at all character it it's
really hard to believe he's decent
he's kind he's good you know it's hard
this is not consistent with my threat
martha maccallum on our side tonight
they look in pain both of them you know
watching it again this was really hard
for them really hard for them and I felt
like they were both kind of just tamping
down the tears they were this close to
crying I think this is obviously
incredibly emotional and devastating
faith I think they thought and we all
thought that that first day the hearing
when Democrats tried to shut down the
whole hearing yes and it couldn't really
get any worse than that and then they
think they're all the way through and
suddenly these accusations start coming
out of the woodwork and I think it would
wreak havoc on anybody they seemed very
solid together and very United in the
effort to because I said to them you
know at some point don't you just say
like forget it
this is it's not worth it anymore it's
too painful but that is not an option
for a job pays you know less than the
average lawyer makes in town you ask
some about their girls their family here
was the response of mrs. Cavanaugh it's
very difficult to have these
conversations with their children which
we've had to have
some broader terms for our youngest but
they know that's Brett and they know the
truth and we told them at the very
beginning of this process this will be
not fun sometimes you're going to hear
things that people feel strongly and you
need to know that and just remember you
know your dad well I bet their girls are
not prepared for this though I mean how
could they be you can imagine at their
age they're like mid you know teens 12
10 and that age range and it's obviously
I'm sure it's devastating for them and
to have to explain you know I asked him
specifically point-blank about all of
the allegations and we talked about them
in very specific graphic terms I can't
imagine what it's like to have to kind
of frame that as she said broadly for
their younger child but you know shields
us of it they know their dad and
remember even in the beginning when he
got roughed up in that first day he said
his daughter came down and gave him a
hug that night so I think he needs a lot
of hugs to get through this period but
you know I mean the allegations are what
they are
I think he's gonna face this on Thursday
Kristine Ford will be heard from she'll
have her moment to speak to make her
peace but there's no doubt that this has
been extraordinarily difficult for them
especially the new allegations over the
week when Clarence Thomas was accused of
inappropriate behavior in 1991 he made a
decision that he was going to fight back
in a very tough way I mean he was not
gonna go down do you think Cavanaugh has
made that decision I Cavanaugh was not
in Clarence Thomas fighting shape today
I'll say that and I played that clip
from Clarence Thomas's when he just
basically leveled the senator Cherryh
committee is so so powerful that is not
the frame of mind that Brett Kavanaugh
appeared to be in today he may be in
that mood on Thursday I even asked him
several times you know you say that this
is all false so what do you think is
behind this where do you think this is
coming from if there's some kind of
political vendetta against you that's
being played out and we all know some of
the corners where that could possibly be
coming from he did not want to go there
at all doesn't want to conjecture about
about any of that and Clarence Thomas
clearly called it what he thought it was
yes
high-tech lynching and he fell
that the Senate Judiciary Committee had
sunk to such lows to entertain some of
the accusations against and that they
entertained that was his feeling yeah
and he persevered so whether or not
we'll see some of that fire in Brett
Kavanaugh come Thursday we'll see he's
gonna need it
martha maccallum congrats on that
interview thanks tucker good to see you